[Música]
[Aplausos]
o essencial é invisível aos olhos
essa é uma frase do livro o pequeno
príncipe que nos traz uma reflexão muito
forte em relação à necessidade nós temos
que acessar aquilo que são os nossos
sentimentos e emoções
se nós quisermos ter um olhar mais
profundo sobre as coisas eu elegi
pessoas como sendo a essência do meu
trabalho fui buscar as bases na
psicologia e desde então prático um
olhar sobre humano no trabalho dentro e
fora das organizações
mas como lidar com o mano falar de
humanos por si só é complexidade cura e
vocês sabem disso devem entender que há
sim uma função tem alguns desafios mas
um dos maiores desafios que eu tenho que
enfrentar na minha trajetória
profissional foi a primeira e última vez
estando na função de responsável de
recursos humanos que tive que chegar pra
alguém e dizer você está demitido
eu não sei se vocês sabem mas quando nós
estamos dentro de uma situação dessas
nós vamos armados
mesmo quase literalmente porque pode
acontecer de a pessoa querer virar
portal nosso pescoço no momento a
informação de tanta raiva
vamos mesmo armado e a coisa funciona
quase como uma estratégia de guerra
primeiro fazemos várias reuniões
secretas várias reuniões onde tentará se
ali pra ver como é que vai ser a reação
que só vai ter um momento de tomar a
notícia
juntamos todos os dados do funcionário
todos principalmente negativos claro até
aquele dia que ele olhou torto pro
colega da cafeína isso também entra
preparamos duas ou três versões do
documento precisa ser assinado
vamos buscar os nossos amigos juristas e
se são servem como uma espécie de escudo
para dar mais credibilidade nas nossas
palavras lei geral do trabalho debaixo
do braço
frases prontas argumentos ensaiados com
as quentão da ameaça e marcamos então o
momento da conversa
vamos buscar uma testemunha também que
sem portanto e no geral os seguranças
também são relacionados que pra dar
tempo de vilhena se ocorrer caso haja
aquela situação do aperto de pescoço
só que nessa situação que disse que
vivenciei já vaiou alguns anos não vou
dizer exatamente quando para não
denunciar muita me dá um senhor de 45
anos uns quase dois metros de altura
daquele tipo klx sabem que mete medo em
todo mundo o cara de mau
ele simplesmente não teve nenhuma
daquelas reações que está no nosso
roteiro ali nacional estratégicas eles
desabou no choro
eu não disse lágrimas não esse choro
mesmo choro daqueles compulsivos que
chamamos de baba e ranho e não agüentava
disse que entende a completamente a
situação nos dava razão pela forma como
o processo estava sendo conduzido
eles não contestaram absolutamente nada
naquele momento ele só queria mesmo era
colo
isso não estava ensaiado não estava nem
um pouco e saia não sabia o que fazer
claro naquela situação completamente
inexperiente ainda por cima fez aquela
cara de paisagem para disfarçar
perguntei se o senhor queria uma água
para poder se acalmar e sair da sala mas
pra pegar água pra mim na verdade
corri para a casa do bairro de forma
disfarçada porque afinal não passava dos
imóveis tem que ser um equilíbrio tem
que ter a coisa e quando cheguei lá eu
chorei também chorei muito
eu me lembro naquele momento do teve
questionado todas as minhas escolhas
sobre carreira até então
enfim foi horrível mas prova sumirá
chora
os documentos foram assinados o processo
foi fechado e correu tudo muito bem
pelo menos do ponto de vista da empresa
mas sim por aquele senhor o teu caixa
o que será que isso significou
em 2006 quando foi feita a escolha da
palavra do ano pela primeira vez em
angola a palavra eleita foi crise
esse é um só que anda ocupado durante
esse período foram estágio de josé ragas
ocupados com esse processo de demissão
que a crise trouxe os números ligados às
reduções pode trabalhos são assustadores
em todos os lados a todos os níveis por
todos os setores
quem aqui não conhece alguém que passou
por isso
aliás quantos aqui muito provavelmente
também passaram por isso
as listas são mesmo longas acontece t
as conseqüências desse processo vão
muito além dos números a crise não é só
econômica e nós precisamos mesmo falar
sobre isso nesse momento eu ocupo um
outro lugar essa história trabalhar em
conta o envolvimento orientação e
transição de carreira eu passei a ocupar
o lugar daquela pessoa que pode dar colo
dentro de um projeto que faço desde 2003
e neste período foram as várias pessoas
que passaram por mim atingidas por essa
avalanche das dimensões e muitas delas
viram grandes multinacionais ou
trabalharam durante anos e é
impressionante como relato dessas
chegava a ser de dor física dor de
barriga dor de cabeça dor no estômago um
desespero total
essa soa simplesmente não tinham perdido
tudo aquilo que eram as suas diferenças
sobre carreira e sobrevida e muitas
delas nesse processo até receberam
pacote indenizatório poderiam garantir
uma estabilidade do sustento durante um
longo período de tempo principalmente
dependendo da forma como esses valores
fossem aplicados
mas a pergunta então que a reflexão que
eu comecei a fazer em torno disso foi
principalmente por causa disso porque
será que esse processo foi tão doloroso
inclusive para essas pessoas
acontece que nós aprendemos a conhecer o
trabalho como como uma afirmação daquilo
que é a de trinidad humana está
empregado nos dias de hoje vai muito
além daquilo que é garantir um salário
para o sustento e diz muito sobre aquilo
que é o lugar que nós ocupamos na
sociedade
por isso mesmo perder o emprego pode ser
uma das experiências mais dolorosas
traumáticas e estressantes que nós
podemos enfrentar na vida e não é só
pela perda da estabilidade financeira e
os resultados vão com a produção dos
sentimentos como fracasso vergonha e
irritação depressão medo insegurança
isso acontece principalmente porque nós
carregamos ali uma certa confusão em
relação aquilo que a diferenciação do
trabalho e emprego e é claro que isso é
tudo parte de uma construção do nosso
imaginário coletivo onde estar empregado
com contrato assinado dentro de uma
empresa estável e ficar ali até o
momento de se aposentar passou a ser um
sinônimo de sucesso aqui na nossa
realidade em angola então se essa
empresa do setor petrolífero e bancário
efe pi vence na vida então ou você tem
alguma coisa muito parecida com essa
ou pode até fazer qualquer outra coisa
nós o teu caminho tem que ser aquela a
sua meta de vida para pessoas como eu
por exemplo que lá que fizeram o caminho
inverso guardado mundo corporativo
próxima aventura no empreendedorismo
essas são loucas core
quem aqui atestar por exemplo ou
trabalha como freelancer ou dentro de
algum outro modelo que não se enquadra
naquele padrão das 8 às 18 com certeza
tem que passar perto mas vê-se por
aquela situação andré quem faz aquela
clássica pergunta mas trabalha como key
à época só depois que eu saiba a
resposta falsa aquela cara de decepção
né mas disfarça que fish
santos mas nunca imaginada além de phu
não trabalha
eu sei que sou das tops também está
acostumado a ouvir em quase todos os
dias por então a nossa noção do trabalho
será que é a mais adequada para os dias
de hoje
eu tenho minhas dúvidas
a idéia trabalho vem desde a escravatura
quando nós tínhamos aquele modelo de
homem objeto que trabalhava e que era
quase uma propriedade de alguém até é
fácil pela era industrial onde já se tem
um modelo do trabalho o homem como
recurso que trabalha em troca de salário
mas quase não mecânico
quanto à prova o próprio equipamento
como se fosse uma extensão da máquina e
até agora nossa era da automação com os
robôs ali a roubarem a cena e nós aqui
com medo de perder todos os nossos
postos de trabalho pra eles
sim porque dizem ter mas 50% das
profissões existentes hoje vão deixar de
existir em muito em breve
olhando pra todos esses modelos
há uma noção do trabalho dessa relação
homem versus trabalho que atravessa o
tempo e tem encaixar o homem naquilo que
nós chamamos de recursos humanos
mas olhando para essa transformação toda
fica muito claro que se nós quisermos
ter um lugar nesse jogo se quisermos
sobreviver a algumas habilidades muito
importantes que precisam ser
desenvolvidas capacidade de enfrentar
desafios
resiliência colaboração equilíbrio e
flexibilidade e espírito empreendedor
foco e determinação e criatividade e
inovação
então se nós vamos olhar pra isso tudo
parece que a coisa toda está muito
difícil pra nós e está difícil mesmo não
tá fácil pra ninguém mas talvez não seja
assim tão impossível porque nós vamos
falar por exemplo sobre o espírito
empreendedor
essa palavra empreendedorismo que está
tão na moda agora ela pode a terceira
novidade da palavra em si mas todos nós
sabemos o tanto de estratégias que nós
temos usado ao longo desses anos todos
quer pra sobreviver durante esses anos
nessa atividade nesse processo
se formos falar sobre colaboração
vamos falar sobre colaboração essa
espírito de partilha do coletivo faz
totalmente parte daquilo que é a nossa
realidade
isso se reflete desde aquelas nossas
tentadas familiares
até acho que silas da vida que são forma
pessoas encontraram de ganhar algum
dinheiro dentro do espírito de total
colaboração e principalmente de muita
confiança e capacidade de enfrentar
desafios nesse quesito
eu não sei mas acho que quase com dor
muscular não todo angolano a mãe parecia
um prémio a nível internacional acho que
o estudo não estávamos bem o que me
parece é que há aqui uma necessidade de
nós nos reinventarmos como ser
produtivos
o problema do desemprego pode e deve ser
resolvido com a criação de novos postos
de trabalho
mas se nós começamos a ter um olhar que
aceita outras formas de produção além
desse mundo
pelo banco barra petrolífera isso por si
só já nos ajudaria a minimizar muitos
dos nossos constrangimentos
muitas pessoas nesse processo de busca
de emprego chegam até nós com os
currículos super pobrinhos quase sem
informação nenhuma além daquela
informação dos dados de identificação ou
se calhar alguma coisa dos dados
acadêmicos mas durante uma conversa uma
entrevista
puxamos um pouco mais o assunto e vamos
descobrir coisas incríveis como é o caso
da lei lá por exemplo que é uma menina
que tinha sempre teve muito boas notas
na escola estava empregada e começou a
dar explicação para os vizinhos ali da
rua
hoje ela tem ali um espaço que montou
perto da data do quintal de casa ao lado
de casa e vai atendendo ali a comunidade
toda fazendo um trabalho de grande
impacto e ao mesmo tempo vai ganhando
seu dinheirinho eo a família por exemplo
que é uma menina que chegou da rússia
conhecer o ano passado dentro desse
processo estava desempregada também e
ela tendo pago algum jeito pra fazer
doces como fazer para vender para os
vizinhos e numa atitude super proativa
fez contato com as escolas além da
região e hoje é fornecedora das campinas
dessas escolas a ganhar um bom dinheiro
também
e ao mesmo tempo claro fazendo um
movimento dentro daquilo que a nossa
economia ou josé que é um rapaz que por
pura curiosidade começou a montar a
antenas parabólicas aprendeu a montar e
hoje já tem até uma equipe de mais ou
menos 100 pessoas que trabalham com ele
e até em tudo quanto é assunto
relacionado à instalação de antenas
parabólicas ali no bairro isso são
algumas das histórias que eu tenho o
privilégio de ouvir quase todos os dias
dentro da minha realidade do trabalho e
essas pessoas deveriam ter os currículos
super ricos porque elas estão ali todos
os dias a desenvolver a habilidade de
gestão controle financeiro
o atendimento ao cliente e inovação e
espírito empreendedor
enfim essas e várias outras coisas
acontece que esse nosso olhar
superficial que está acostumado com este
modelo simplesmente não conseguem chegar
essas conferências
só que essas competências que estão cada
vez a ser mais valorizadas a nível
global estão aí todos os dias dentro da
nossa realidade
então todos os dias aí só que os nossos
modelos de sucesso no geral sua busca
inspiração nos steve jobs da vida mas eu
tenho certeza que todos nós aqui e eu
desafio mesmo dizendo todos
todos nós temos referências da nossa
vida história familiar e outras relações
de pessoas que nos dão lições diárias
que estão à altura de qualquer se o
nível global o que é preciso é que cada
um de nós cada pessoa cada organização e
todos nós como nação
façamos a tarefa de casa no sentido de
perceber qual é o nosso papel dentro
desse jogo
qual é o nosso papel dentro dessa
produção qual é o nosso papel nessa
função do trabalho e perceber o trabalho
como uma actividade que valoriza as
nossas potencialidades
aquilo que são as nossas potencialidades
e empreendedoras artísticas inovadoras
criativas e principalmente locais
infelizmente eu não tive mais nenhuma
notícia daquele tio caixa que chorou a
minha frente no processo da demissão
talvez ela esteja deprimido até hoje
talvez tenha encontrado um outro emprego
ou talvez tenha encontrado outras formas
de exercer o seu poder produtivo
isso nós não sabemos o que eu espero com
certeza é que essa história nos sirva de
inspiração para refletirmos todos os
dias
sobre as diferenças e as infinitas
formas de fazermos mover a nossa
economia porque dependemos da habilidade
e se eu tenho certeza que nós temos de
sobra
o essencial é invisível aos olhos e pra
nós termos esse olhar é preciso nós de
educar mas o nosso eu
no sentido de nos libertarmos desses
modelos e percebermos aquilo que são as
nossas potencialidades todos os dias
obrigado
[Aplausos]